let's fight with hope
let's fight with confidence in ourselves
and a commitment to each other
to the america we know is
possible kamala harris delivered a
powerful speech during wednesday night's
democratic national convention
today that country feels distant
donald trump's failure of leadership has
cost
lives and livelihoods the constant
chaos leaves us adrift
the incompetence makes us feel afraid
the callousness makes us feel alone
it's a lot and here's the thing
we can do better and deserve
so much more hollywood cheered her on
as she accepted the party's vice
presidential nomination
cementing her status as the first black
woman and first person of indian descent
to do so
that i am here tonight is a testament to
the dedication of generations before me
women and men who believed so fiercely
in the promise of equality liberty
and justice for all celebrities watching
at home couldn't help but share their
reactions to the senator's empowering
words
just excited about the future mandy
moore was in tears
tweeting what a night flabbergasted at
the immense weight of words all around
our soon-to-be madame vice president is
truly the future
she raised us to be proud strong
black women and she raised us
to know and be proud of our indian
heritage
in kamala's captivating speech she
listed all those whose shoulders she
stands on
praising her mother and the importance
of family
family is my best friend my nieces
and my god children family is my uncles
my aunts and my chitties it's quite
humbling and
really beautiful padma lakshmi who was
born in india wrote
i literally have tears in my eyes kamala
harris just said chittis which means
auntie
my heart is so full right now we must
elect
a president who will bring something
different
something better and do the important
work a president who will bring
all of us together black white latino
asian indigenous to achieve the future
we collectively
want we must
elect joe biden john legend complimented
kamala's words calling her speech full
of eloquence
emotion and moral weight we hope to
inspire people
while mariah carey noted the importance
of the night
simply tweeting witnessing history this
virus
it has no eyes and yet it knows
exactly how we see each other
and how we treat each other
and let's be clear there is no
vaccine for racism kerry washington who
hosted the third night of the virtual
convention
tweeted that powerful moment bette
midler
also shared her two cents tweeting great
speech
socially distant this is so weird but so
so moving
and full of hope but the moment that was
trending
this
yep kamala harris finished her historic
speech
by walking off to mary j blige's classic
song
work thought
the moment lit twitter on fire and
charlemagne the gods tweet said it all
we've got to do the work
you